[Musique]
et cet invité c'est michel bussi bonjour
merci d'accepter notre invitation vous
êtes écrivain on vous connaît comme
auteur à succès vos livres sont adaptées
en séries télévisées votre dernier livre
s'intitule nouvelle babel mais vous avez
aussi michel bussi une autre casquette
peu connu et c'est à ce titre que vous
êtes sur notre antenne ce matin vous
êtes géographe ancien directeur de
recherche au cnrs spécialiste des
cartographies électorale première
question évidemment on pourra parler
littérature est avec vous tout à l'heure
mais que vous inspire ce second tour au
maquereau le pen auquel nous nous
assistons compense le spécialiste des
cartes électorales que vous êtes en fait
on assiste à quelque chose contrairement
à ce que beaucoup dit je pense d'assez
classique et qu'on avait déjà vu en 2017
c'est à dire une répartition de la vie
politique avec un un blog qui ont à dire
d'extrême droite qui fait à peu près un
tiers des voix un bloc on va dire
globalement de droite qui correspond
globalement aux votes des manuels bac
rond puisque il a essentiellement
siphonner les voix de valérie pécresse
des républicains et puis un bloc de
gauche
représenté par jean luc mélenchon qui
lui a sonné les voies globalement du
parti socialiste et et des écologistes
en tout cas plutôt trois blocs mais
comme que deux places au second tour va
évidemment se retrouve avec un duel et
une partie notamment la partie gauche de
la population qui va déterminer en
grande partie le résultat du second tour
et selon certains analystes
michel bussi voir marine le pen
elle-même cette élection oppose les
classes populaires aux élites le
sous-entendu étant que l'électorat
populaire sur est acquis à marine le pen
et les élites ou assimilés élite à
emmanuel macron est ce qu'il y à du vrai
là-dedans que disent les données alors
il ya forcément une part de vrai puisque
depuis très longtemps le front national
aujourd'hui leur fondateur rassemblement
national et le parti le plus fort chez
les catégories comme les ouvriers comme
les chômeurs notamment donc on va dire
sur l'airé où les moins diplômées donc
les cartes hickory les plus populaires
ça ce n'est pas nouveau déjà jean marie
le pen a obtenu des scores de 30% chez
les ch et les précaires
néanmoins une fois qu'on a dit ça on
peut pas non plus oublier que par
exemple l'électorat de gauche qui est
qui qui a fait quasiment jeu égal avec
marine le pen le premier tour on aura
noté par jean 2000 ans on a réussi
également à récupérer beaucoup de voix
dans les quartiers populaires notamment
beaucoup de voix auprès des populations
immigrés l'on te pas ou d'origine
immigrés qui représentera une sorte
population en france et dans l'outre-mer
et que cette population là ces électeurs
là ne se reconnaissent absolument pas
dans le discours de marine le pen est à
dire qu on a eu tendance à me poser
beaucoup les électeurs qui des prévenus
préoccupé par la fin du mois qu'ils
seraient les électeurs populaires les
électeurs préoccupés par la soeur du
monde qui serait plutôt aux électeurs on
dirait de l'élite et d'emmanuel battront
pas de problèmes pour boucler leurs fins
de mois mais qui se préoccupe plutôt
de problèmes mondiaux en fait je crois
que c'est pas tout à fait vrai c'est à
dire qu'il est aussi grande partie des
lecteurs qui se préoccupe pour la fois
du mois s'il gagne pas beaucoup d'argent
sur les classes moyennes pauvres mais
qui se moque du possible la fin du monde
c'est à dire qu'on en parle dans tous
ces fameux
personnes qui étaient au front donc
ces dernières aux fonctionnaires ou
trois éducateurs ou gens qui travaillent
dans le balo si tel est bien ce sont des
gens ou mais nous étudions ce sont des
gens qui à la fois évidemment eu des
problèmes de faim du bois mais quand
aussi une forte conscience du sort du
monde pro prenant les étudiants qui se
font partie des populations les plus
précaires ce sont généralement des gens
qui y vivent sont diplômés suivre des
études et qui pour beaucoup ne se
reconnaissent pas dans le discours de
marine le pen et aspirent à des
questions d'ordre global même s'ils sont
très sensibles c'est la foire de six à
douze fois que c'est un petit peu
réducteur quand on tape des élites de
quoi on parle est ce que ce sont des
élites par exemple qui possède des
diplômes parce que son d'élite il
possède des gros salaires voilà est-ce
qu'un petit pas trop qui gagne bien sa
vie c'est une élite est ce que quelqu'un
d'étudiants qui à bac + 5 mais qui gagne
mais le service est une élite cc c'est
très compliqué et je pense que du coup
on se tromperait notamment dans là
c'était très nouveau quand même c'est
comme une somme d'opposition emmanuel
macron d une partie de la gauche qui
hésitent à voter pour lui malgré la
menace incroyable de l'arrivée au
pouvoir il le pen je l'avais jamais été
aussi proche ces câbles témoigne à skis
à une partie de la population qui ne se
reconnaît pas dans les élites fils se
reconnaissent pas dans une politique
libérale habitants millions les voilà
justement michel mercier nouveau fait
dire que je ne veulent pas être
considérés dans le corps d élite juste
un match que je joue très long car ils y
sont pas justement michel bussi ce qu'on
note on a bien compris à l'histoire du
clivage géographique ou encore du
clivage générationnel
un mot tout de même sur 10 aces
barrières idéologiques pour les appeler
ainsi qui semble s'être affaissé marine
le pen ne fait plus peur plus autant en
tout cas certains note même une espèce
de confusion entre droite extrême et
extrême droite est ce qu'on est en train
d'assister en france à une recomposition
sur le plan idéologique
moi je crois pas je crois pas parce
qu'en fait on s'aperçoit lac
il ya un très fort barrage contre marine
le pen ya un front républicain qui se
met en place comme il s'est mis en place
auparavant bien entendu tant qu'eric
zemmour était là sur ce premier tour
marine le pen n'était à l'abri derrière
eric zemmour et qui vire au delà dit
souvent observé paratonnerre et du coup
forcément elle pouvait elle n'a
pratiquement pas parlé d'immigration
pendant sa campagne bien ça tombe de
mesure phare de son programme comme
interdire le port du voile dans la rue
par exemple
ou renvoyer chez nous les étrangers
s'ils sont au chômage goudineau par
exemple dans des besoins qu'on a très
peu entendu évoqué parce que le thème de
l'immigration étaient essentiellement
portée par zemmour et du coup marine le
pen pouvait se contenter globalement
d'un programme social or aujourd'hui
évidemment le débat porte sur l'ensemble
de son programme avait le cul avec
zemmour qui paratonnerre et donc là
effectivement beaucoup d'électeurs ils
se pensent notamment une nouvelle fois
aux électeurs de gauche qui sont ceux
qui seront les plus partagées qui se
prévaut certains autres la plus grosse
réserve de voix
qui vont se dire mais je peux le
parterre barrage à une candidate qui par
exemple va interdire le port du voile
dans la rue ce qui est évidemment
provoquerait santé en est conscient
sandy de très grande tension
qui serait l'opposé de son idée donnera
de rassembler les français
bien entendu il est donc effectivement
parce qu'elles sont des mesures qui me
semble assez opposée à ce que peut être
global brut dont une opinion de gauche
donc donc se trouve pas que l'on conçoit
qu'on est comme ça je pense que
aujourd'hui les gens redécouvrent et
puis même si marine le pen parvient à
lisser son image notamment une image
c'est maternante à l'opposé finalement
de notre père ne gagnera d'autres
leaders populistes qui sont seules font
ils se sont fait lire plutôt sur une sur
la virilité il l'appelle joue plutôt
quelque chose de très rare mais entre
guillemets c'est lieutenant de marine le
pen pour sa part des live ça reste quand
même sur une rhétorique extrêmement
extrêmement forte et extrêmement
classique extrêmement même parfois
violentes dans l'or
michel bussi quand on considère le taux
d'abstention est ce que l'élection
présidentielle est encore la mère de
toutes les élections en france alors moi
je le dirai non j'irai loler évidemment
les médias sont excessivement concentrer
sur l'élection présentielle bien entendu
l'élection présidentielle par sa hutte
aux permanents et dès le début du second
tour on va commencer à parler d'élection
2027 en se disant tiens qui seront les
candidats espère à repenser des noirs
chili voilà donc c'est un feuilleton
permanence est on est on est dans des
saisons
un terminal néanmoins on ne va pas
oublier aujourd'hui que l'élection
présidentielle déjà un taux d'abstention
considérable et que son vote les
français votent très différemment dans
les dés sont essentielles et dans les
élections aux dix intermédiaires sur les
élections municipales régionales
départementales à ce point que les
régions les départements et les grandes
communes sont presque entièrement se
partage entre deux partis le parti
socialiste et les républicains tous les
élus locaux pratiquement appartiennent à
ces deux groupes qui ne font plus que
cumuler 6% du présidentielle et on
pourrait même se dire quelques celle
inverse c'est à dire que pour qu'un
président soit élu aujourd'hui dans
l'esprit des français il faut qu'il soit
en dehors des partis dès lors qu'un
candidat qui traite d'un parti derrière
lui il le traîne comme un boulet alors
que pourrait être un élu local il faut
avoir parti derrière soi parce qu'il
faut montrer qu'on est capable de gérer
avec des moyens quotidiens en doc on a
presque eu une inversion c'est à dire
qu'il ya un candidat qui est élu local
aujourd'hui à la présidentielle le trail
on l'a vu entre valérie pécresse et
qu'on dit anne hidalgo sa presque
étaient des handicaps pour eux d'être
des élus locaux merci piloté par partie
merci beaucoup michel bussi pour votre
éclairage votre analyse romancier à
succès mais aussi géographe spécialiste
des cartographie électorale dernier
livre paru nouvelle babel aux éditions
la président a cité ce était l'invité de